[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
las medidas para contener la pandemia
del cob y 19 dejaron a muchos
deportistas en el limbo y con la
suspensión de los juegos olímpicos de
tokio que estaban previstos para julio
de este año algunos tenían dificultades
para mantener sus entrenamientos de alto
rendimiento pero consiguieron avanzar
con sus rutinas les contamos cómo lo
hizo un grupo de velocistas en colombia
y hay tensión en la recta final de las
selecciones de bolivia que fueron
aplazadas tras su anulación hace un año
también por la pandemia del cob y 19
insultos y agresiones han marcado la
típica campaña para reemplazar a evo
morales quien estuvo casi 15 años en el
poder
y a poco más de tres semanas para las
elecciones presidenciales en eeuu en
aquí américa les tenemos un segmento
especial para revisar y entender el
camino hacia la casa blanca hoy hablamos
del primer y único debate de
vicepresidentes
y vamos de inmediato a colombia para
nuestra historia principal en medio de
un año atípico tras el aplazamiento de
los juegos olímpicos de tokio hasta
julio de 2021 un grupo de velocistas
colombianos avanza con su preparación
para esta cita la pandemia interrumpió
sus rutinas pero hablamos con el equipo
de relevo masculino y mixto del país
cafetero que quiere hacer historia el
próximo año en la capital japonesa
-juan pupiales estuvo con ellos
son parte de la élite del atletismo de
velocidad de sudamérica ahora reunidos
en bogotá para un entrenamiento con
altura del alexander gilmar jennifer
diego antón y lina integran un proyecto
de colombia que dirige el experimentado
entrenador cubano nelson gutiérrez con
la ilusión de brillar en el relevo
masculino y mixto en los juegos de tokio
queremos seguir soñando con una medalla
la idea es esa o sea no lo vamos a
cambiar realmente vemos vamos a ver cómo
se va desarrollando toda la preparación
hoy por hoy ya podemos trabajar ya
tenemos otra otra esperanza en el
trabajo sostenido anthony zambrano
sorprendió el mundo el año pasado con
una plata en el mundial de atletismo de
doha en los 400 metros planos el equipo
terminó en cuarta plaza un gran momento
que se congeló con el aplazamiento de
los juegos ya yo que venía de hacer
segundo en un mundial venía con mucha
ansiedad muchas ganas de ser finalista
olímpico pero además hemos advertido
como que la ilusión ni nada eso me ha
sido como que más fuerte porque yo
siento que eso fue como con una barrera
como un obstáculo
la pandemia ha marcado su preparación
unos pudieron ir a entrenar un tiempo
lisboa otros recibían instrucciones de
manera virtual ahora este año termina
con una aparente normalidad este año
digamos que pese a lo duro ha sido más
bien para enseñarnos y nos ha permitido
enfocarnos en lo que realmente queremos
bueno se nos dio la posibilidad de estar
en europa
entrenando y ya bueno ahora estamos aquí
continuando la preparación y con mucha
ilusión ha sido muy difícil porque creo
que cada uno de nosotros tenía una meta
tenía como que su su visión y su
ambición de mejorar en lo personal se
alejó un poco nuestro sueño pero sí
intacto
compiten en una categoría que no es una
especialidad de la región y ante unos
rivales de europa y norteamérica que han
tenido más facilidades para entrenar en
la pandemia pero el camino a tokio aún
no ha terminado
en bolivia la campaña para las
elecciones presidenciales se lleva a
cabo principalmente a través de redes
sociales no solo por las medidas para
contener el kobe 19 sino porque el ex
presidente evo morales se encuentra en
el exilio desde su renuncia hace casi un
año en medio de denuncias de fraude a su
favor en los comicios según un sondeo de
tu voto cuenta el heredero del poder
político de evo morales luis arse lidera
la intención de voto con el 33% la
oposición que está dividida sigue entre
el opositor carlos meza con un 26% y
fernando camacho con apenas 13%
los bolivianos están listos para volver
a las urnas una elección que ha sido
aplazado durante casi un año las
elecciones del 20 de octubre de 2019
fueron anuladas por denuncias de fraude
a favor del entonces presidente evo
morales lo que desató una crisis sin
precedentes recientes en el país santino
que había sido liderado por el indígena
desde 2006 nosotros no queremos que el
presidente continue ve porque porque
esta persona se ha convertido en 'la en
tirano contra nuestra propia bolivia
entonces es alguien que ya no es
bienvenido en bolivia es alguien que
está abusando esta autoridad tanto él
como los demás trabajadores que están
con el destruido luciendo en medio de
protestas y luego de que las fuerzas
militares le retiraron su apoyo morales
renunció y viajó a méxico para después
exiliarse en argentina si planteé
elecciones libres y transparentes y
acabé en la persecución política y que
me de gente de bolivia pero a pesar de
estar fuera del país morales es
probablemente la figura política más
importante de bolivia y divide
piedad entre quienes alaban sus
políticas y lo ven como el salvador de
la luz con la nacionalización de la
industria de hidrocarburos que permitió
que el producto interno bruto del país
creciera cinco por ciento en sus
primeros cinco años en el palacio
quemado y entre quienes consideran que
destruyó la democracia al hacer uso de
maniobras jurídicas para perpetuarse en
el poder e ignorar el referendo de 2016
cuando los bolivianos le dijeron que no
podía aspirar a un nuevo mandato
presidencial nosotros lo que queremos es
la paz en bolivia queremos el orden
constitucional y estamos haciendo los
esfuerzos la polarización desde entonces
se ha visto en manifestaciones en las
calles y en torno a sus sucesoras
jeanine áñez quien se autodenominó
presidenta interina de bolivia el 12 de
noviembre de 2019
tras las controversiales divisiones del
vicepresidente álvaro garcía linera y la
presidenta del senado
adriana salvatierra ambos cercanos a evo
morales
la que ahora es la oposición al partido
del expresidente el movimiento al
socialismo está dividida entre su
candidato luis arse y el centrista
carlos meza y empezamos nuestro segmento
especial de aquí américa camino a la
casa blanca el espacio semanal para
seguir la contienda entre el presidente
de donald trump y el candidato demócrata
joe biden de cara a las elecciones del 3
de noviembre hoy vamos a hablar del
primer y único debate entre los
vicepresidentes entre mike pence y
kamala harris tras el vergonzoso primer
debate entre el presidente de donald
trump y el candidato demócrata joe biden
marcado por los insultos y las
interrupciones los candidatos a la
vicepresidencia se enfrentaron en un
cara a cara más civilizado y con medidas
de sanidad más estrictas luego de que
trump fuera diagnosticado positivo por
kobe 19 los candidatos fueron separados
por paneles de plexiglás y a la
audiencia se le prohibió quitarse la
mascarilla tras las críticas a los
funcionarios de la casa blanca que se la
retiraron en
bate presidencial
y aunque también un nuevo interrupciones
por parte del vicepresidente mike pence
a la senadora y candidata kamala harris
esta vez sí hubo discusión de los planes
de gobierno el debate se centró en la
crisis del cob y 19 la vacante en la
corte suprema y la política exterior el
vicepresidente evitó comprometerse con
un intercambio pacífico del poder en
caso de perder las elecciones permítanme
decirles que creo que vamos a ganar
estas elecciones el presidente de trump
y yo estamos luchando todos los días en
los tribunales para evitar que joe biden
y kamala harris cambian las reglas y
cree en este correo universal en la
votación que creará una gran oportunidad
para el fraude electoral
si tenemos unas elecciones libres y
justas sabemos que vamos a tener
confianza y creo en mi corazón que el
presidente de donald trump será
reelegido por cuatro años más
harris por su parte tuvo momentos
brillantes como cuando atacó a la actual
administración por no condenar a los
grupos de supremacistas blancos y lanzó
duras críticas a trump por su gestión de
el coronavirus
y el pueblo estadounidense ha sido
testigo del que ha sido el mayor fracaso
de cualquier administración presidencial
en la historia de nuestro país sin poder
imaginarse si ustedes hubieran sabido el
28 de enero en vez del 13 de marzo lo
que ellos sabían lo que ustedes habrían
hecho para prepararse ellos sabían y lo
encubrieron el presidente dijo que era
un engaño
el presidente dijo están en un lado si
usan una mascarilla están del otro lado
si no lo hacen lanzar más grandes
artistas matter if it down y los debates
a la vicepresidencia generalmente no
tienen tanto impacto pero este año
cobraron especial atención debido al
diagnóstico positivo de kobe 19 del
presidente trump ya que pensó subiría el
poder si cayera gravemente enfermo y
bailén ya anticipado que no aspiraría un
segundo mandato dejando a cámara como la
opción entonces quien ganó en este
debate según la cadena cnn el 58% de las
mujeres cree que harris lo hizo mejor y
el 30 que el vicepresidente
los hombres por su parte cree que fue un
empate
vamos a hablar con nuestra corresponsal
en san francisco susana mendoza
susana empiezo por preguntarte cuál es
la importancia del cargo de
vicepresidente en eeuu
hola buenas el cargo de vicepresidente
es muy importante aquí en eeuu
principalmente porque en caso de
ocurrirle algo al presidente sería el
vicepresidente o sea el segundo de
abordo el que tomaría poner pues el
liderazgo el que asumiría la presidencia
de este país así que es muy importante a
quien se elige para acompañar al líder
de este país tanto es así de hecho que
por ejemplo cuando john kennedy fue
asesinado y los años 60 quien le
reemplazó fue el vicepresidente
clinton de johnson que además bueno
compartía de los ideales del tanto
kennedy en cuestiones de derechos
civiles y por lo cual prosiguió el
legado de kennedy johnson también tuvo
otras otras decisiones peores como por
ejemplo aumentar el número de tropas
que iban a vietnam pero a pesar de esto
si continúa el legado entonces por eso
es muy importante que los
vicepresidentes si esté en la misma
línea que el presidente aunque sea bueno
más moderado en ciertos temas aparte de
esto por lo general la vicepresidencia
también se ve como una especie de
trampolín a la presidencia una vez que
se termine el cargo del actual
presidente
y precisamente entonces porque este año
esta figura ha cobrado una importancia
inédita
bueno porque se considera que hay mucho
más juego más en juego este año quizá
que en otros años electorales y porque
la candidata del partido demócrata
kamala harris es muy conocida en
política y además bastante bien pista en
general en sectores demócratas
harris es una veterana de la justicia de
aquí en california ya que ejerció el
cargo de fiscal general de este estado
hasta el año 2017 con bastantes luces
pero también con algunas sombras como
por ejemplo no querer reformar el
sistema de prisiones en california
creo que harris está bastante en el ojo
político este año también porque va a ir
en es un candidato sino el de mayor edad
hasta ahora uno de los que sí sería
bueno pues de mayor edad con lo cual las
posibilidades de que no llegue a
terminar su mandato serían quizá más
grandes que en otras ocasiones así que
la batuta presidencial y bueno pues
caería en manos d
y este año además también precisamente
se enfrentan dos candidatos que no
podían ser más opuestos diametralmente
harris es una mujer de color de padre
afroamericano y madre india liberal
contra mike pence un hombre blanco ultra
conservador y religioso gracias a
nuestra corresponsal en san francisco
susana mendoza por su intervención en
este segmento especial de aquí américa
camino a la casa blanca ya ustedes
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
recuerden que pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas cuídense mucho del coronavirus
y sigan viendo france24
[Música]